ha Basava and his cousin Sahara
are desperate to leave the to Afghan
refugees are exasperated they've been
stranded in a run-down area just behind
Belgrade Central Station over the course
of several months this area is developed
into an illegal refugee encampment today
the serbian government has sent a bus to
relocate children in the sick - an
official refugee camp for over three
months the two slept in this car park
near the station at temperatures as low
as minus 20 degrees this is one of
Belgrade's luxury real estate projects
just a stone's throw away Afghan and
Pakistani refugees burn old wooden
railroad ties to keep warm toxic fumes
are everywhere they're waiting to hear
from human traffickers at the Hungarian
and Croatian borders if it's worth
risking crossing into EU territory
but the borders are shut some families
have paid five thousand euros to send
their children to Western Europe now
they're stuck in Serbia's capital
sheltering in disused warehouses all
they've got left is the hope that they
might be able to continue their journey
someday
Saharan ha they are worn out fed up with
living in squalor yes is going to came
better for me I'm no problem one to man
better for me eating everything
available that the dream still manages a
man I'm in pain there are metal
splinters in my arm from the operation I
need to see a doctor Poway says the
Taliban kidnapped and almost killed him
his arm was broken and he received only
very basic medical treatment he still
hopes he can receive medical help in
Germany both Afghans say there are human
traffickers everywhere opposite them at
the luka Jade ovitch Park those refugees
who can afford it are buying hot food
conspicuously many of them are checking
their smartphones there are good reasons
for this
Gordon Powe no [ __ ] knows why the parks
and networking hotspot for traffickers
voinovich runs next door's info park aid
center which supports many refugees
who've been stranded in Serbia this park
has become a famous smuggler spots is
the main smugglers hotspot in whole
serbia over the past year the square has
become known as Afghani Park there are
train and bus stops nearby and if you
need a contact with a smuggler or you
you were told by your contact in Sofia
in Bulgaria or Turkey wherever you're
coming from
go to Afghani Park and find the grill
this is it you know and here usually
have a few guys who can facilitate the
continuation of your travel the Serbian
government turns a blind eye it's blind
to see the refugees move on even though
no one says so in so many words
it is something coped by the Ministry of
Interior in a very successful way I have
to say because if you look at the
official data official figures many of
them were arrested Prosser and and
processed so but there's the problem all
the countries on the route of fighting
weights but ever since the EU countries
sealed their borders Serbia has been
struggling to cope with the refugees did
you just come from the border yes where
did you go to Croatia and how is the
situation butter is too much hard
we cannot go police problem please
hitting us this is driving up
traffickers fees for facilitating a
border crossing on route to Western
Europe how much money to to Hungary and
Croatia how much to Austria two thousand
thousands of euros without knowing if
they'll actually make it across the
border for javi and his cousins our hair
that's simply too much money Xavier
hopes the Europeans will recognize that
he fled the Taliban in Afghanistan and
grant him asylum I hope they'll let me
travel to Germany legally I can no
longer travel with people smugglers due
to my injury those who are healthy have
a chance of crossing the border for me
that's impossible Serbia has become a
dead end for Refugees even for those
with a legitimate right to claim asylum
in the EU